hoy Como sucede en muchos países del
Mundo también es el Día de la madre en
Ucrania y coincide con un precioso día
de primavera en el cual tanto madres
hijos y los padres que están presentes
están celebrando en esta ciudad pero
cuesta creer que solamente anoche
sonaron en dos ocasiones las alarmas
algunas ciudades del país incluido
Quienes fueron atacadas con misiles y
con drones y así ha venido sucediendo
sistemáticamente a lo largo de las
últimas semanas lo que ha vuelto a
revivir los fantasmas y el temor de
especialmente de estos niños ya no Solo
lo que vivieron al comienzo de esa
invasión a gran escala el 24 de febrero
del año pasado cuando Rusia decidió
invadir a Ucrania en este momento la
ciudad quedó totalmente desértica las
madres los niños los padres que podían
salían se los llevaban de aquí ha pasado
muchas cosas desde entonces pero desde
octubre empezaron a atacar la
sistemáticamente de la ciudad y el resto
del país para destruir la
infraestructura eléctrica con el
objetivo de minar la moral de la
población ucraniana que ha demostrado
durante estos 15 meses de guerra que es
bastante fuerte y que están decididos a
resistir Pero esto no significa que no
haya sido un invierno extremadamente
duro para los niños y para las madres
que han tenido que ser los Pilares de
esas casas sosteniendo por ejemplo a
esos niños cuyos padres están en el
frente de batalla y no saben si van a
regresar o que les han tenido que contar
que sus padres han fallecido y así que
es bastante significativo que este día
de las madres coincida con un día tan
bonito en Ucrania en kiev donde aman la
primavera está lleno de Castaños que
están en este momento florecidos y así
decenas de árboles y se ve como estos
niños hoy disfrutan lo que cuesta hacer
recordar lo difícil que han vivido y lo
difícil que siguen siendo algunos
momentos especialmente en las noches
cuando son atacados